habe ich also viele leute mitgekriegt
aber diese woche gab es in berlin einen
runden tisch zum thema plastikmüll
plastikmüll vermeiden vielmehr handel
industrie und unsere umweltministerin
suchen nach neuen konzepten zur
müllvermeidung wobei die plastik
hersteller das meiste erst mal
freiwillig machen sollen getreu dem
motto dieser groko und seid ihr nicht
willig dann lassen wir es halt dabei
sind wir deutschen europäischer
spitzenreiter bei plastikmüll
warum ist es bei uns nicht gesetzlich
geregelt wie viel recycelbarem material
in seiner verpackung sein muss dass
weniger plastik eingesetzt wird dass man
mehr mehrwegbehälter messe hat das sind
alles dinge die heute hier schon
zugesagt wurden und ich hoffe dass das
dadurch deutlich schneller geht als wenn
wir das gesetzlich machen würden
und ich meine mehr als hoffen kann eine
ministerin nicht das wissen sie wir
haben zwar ein neues verpackungs gesetz
aber das passiert im kern auch auf dem
prinzip hoffnung gerade im umgang mit
der lebensmittelindustrie legt diese
groko wert auf freiwilligkeit gilt auch
für unsere ernährungsministerin julia
klöckner
beim schwierigen thema zucker ganz
wichtiges problem in england in england
werden getränke mit zuckerzusatz
besteuert wir haben seit dezember ihre
freiwillige nationale reduktion
strategie für zucker und fett so die
deutsche diabetes gesellschaft hat er
war gerade beschlossen dann nicht mehr
mitzumachen der freiwillige einsatz sei
und ich zitiere praktisch wirkungslos
ja und warum haben wir keine für alle
verbindliche lebensmittelampel da könnte
jeder sofort sehen wie ungesund das
futter ist dass er sich gerade kauft
geht aber nicht weil wenn wir nämlich
drei farben leuchten auf einem produkt
dann ist das wie im straßenverkehr dann
gibt es verwirrung
[Musik]
gut
bei welcher ampel leuchtenden alle
treffer haben gleichzeitig vielleicht
könnt ihr auf dem dorf das kann doch
nicht wahr sein und hermann julia was
ist denn stattdessen deine strategie ich
versuche mal mit zu schreiben wir werden
zum beispiel das sind vereinbarungen 20
prozent zucker und den frühstücks
cerealien reduzieren aber nicht in jeder
serien sind gleich viele zuckergehalte
drin und da gehen wir differenziert ran
und wir wollen auch dass die kleinen
handwerksbetriebe wie zb die bäckereien
wissenschaftliche begleitung haben wenn
salz ist nicht nur geschmacks geben
sondern für die konsistenz wichtig und
auch für die haltbarkeit wie silber ging
es bei salz gewandelt das gibt's doch
gar nicht
hier bin ich das
das ist
das ist wirklich einer methode das macht
thema dieses so lange herum bis ich
vergessen dass sie eigentlich was machen
müsste wie hat die zucker lobby
durchgesetzt dass dutzende zuckerarten
auf verpackungen bei uns nicht zucker
genannt werden müssen warum ist zucker
in babynahrung bei uns immer noch
erlaubt wegen freiwilligkeit
immerhin finden wir jetzt ein tierwohl
label auch schon seit zig jahren
versprochen dann haben schweine im stall
20 prozent mehr platz 20 prozent mehr
platz das ist eine ansage aber hallo
emma 20 prozent sind da ansage es ist
eine enorme verbesserung sogar wirklich
ja gut das tierwohl label geht jetzt
leider nur für schweine
pech für die anderen tiere und 20
prozent mehr platz heißt in wirklichkeit
wir erhöhen erstmal von 0,75
quadratmeter pro schwein auf 0,9 ja das
wär ich habe ihnen das mal mitgebracht
so viel mehr platz pro tier
da sag ich mal macht euch gemütlich ja
und der eigentliche skandal
die landwirte müssen nicht mitmachen es
ist da kommen sie nie drauf freiwillig
das gleiche elend beim thema
lebensmittel wegschmeißen
auch da sind für deutschland europa ganz
weit vorne während in deutschland über
80 kilogramm lebensmittel pro kopf und
jahr weggeworfen werden sind es in
frankreich nur 20 bis 30
ja gut also das kann man aber gar nicht
vergleichen ich meine in frankreich ist
das essen lecker
ja
warum soll man das wegschmeißen es macht
ja keinen sinn bei uns freunde
bei uns geht die
lebensmittelverschwendung tatsächlich
zur hälfte aufs konto der privaten
verbraucher ja auf unser aller konto das
muss man schon muss man sich auch mal
kritisch an die eigene nase fassen aber
dagegen kämpft julia klöckner mit ihrer
freiwilligen initiative zu gut für die
tonne so die gibt es seit wir haben
nachgeguckt 2012 gebracht hat sie nicht
immerhin hat die ministerin jetzt etwas
für restaurantbesuche erfunden was unser
aller leben für immer verändern wird und
dann haben wir entwickelt eine feste
oder einer reste box also verwenden
statt verschwenden die ist richtig gut
kann ich ihnen sagen also restlos
genießen wäre es ein kleines häppchen
dann dran hält auch flüssigkeiten zu
meiner kindheit war das normal da hat
man das essen dann im restaurant
eingepackt dann wird's irgendwie uncool
und jetzt ist es wieder in das ist das
ist so derartig in jetzt wirklich mal
das ist so sensationell was die frau
klöckner da erfunden hat ich weiß ich
weiß gar nicht wie ich ihnen das
erklären soll das ist im prinzip ja so
eine art pappkarton und für mich jetzt
schon die schlüsseltechnologie der
zukunft damit ja damit kann man nämlich
essen regelrecht transportieren
ich habe ja alles aufgeboten weil ich
nicht wusste dass so etwas überhaupt
möglich ist hier wirklich demonstrieren
dass jetzt mal dieses von mir nur halb
aufgegessen mettbrötchen so aufpassen
das kann ich jetzt in die reste box
reintun und jetzt kommt er erst der
knaller findet bitte damit nach hause
gehen
[Applaus]
ist das der wahnsinn
ist doch der wahnsinn
mit dem reuigen
juli als das ist viel besser als die
meisten presst
das ist die beste
[Musik]
spontan
[Applaus]
ganz so glücklich
so
und das alles verdammt werden nur der
erfindung von julia klöckner damen und
herren verstehen sie mich nicht falsch
das ist sicher gut gemeint und wir
verbraucher bauen auch oft viel scheiße
ich finds halt nur irgendwie lustig dass
dieselben ministerin die keinen bock
haben sich mit der industrie anzulegen
uns offenbar für komplette vollidioten
halten denen man alles erklären muss zum
beispiel mit glocken hass zu gut für die
tonne app lauter originalzitate julia
klöckner kümmert sich endlich um unser
schlimmstes problem den und verspätungen
verbraucher endlich
wir sind aber auch wirklich zu gut für
alle also klockner tipp nummer eins wir
sollen vor dem einkaufen einen
sogenannten einkaufszettel schreiben ja
hier steht notieren was gebraucht wird
zettel mit zum einkauf nehmen und daran
halten
ach so dass man sich quasi vorher
darüber gedanken machen was man braucht
und ich meine wir dazu da immer in den
supermarkt und kaufen irgendeine chance
beim angriff ohne druck entscheiden
gerade wenn du hungrig oder ihn an lewis
sind sonderangebote verführerisch
[Musik]
[Gelächter]
lass mich mal ein täglicher
kontrollblick in den kühlschrank reicht
meist aus um festzustellen was fehlt und
was noch vorhanden ist
besonders du dich an deine sinne riechen
probieren schmecken nur was wirklich
streng riecht gehört in den büchern
ich versuche jetzt komplett auf
verpackung braucht man nicht ich habe
eier und nutella gekauft
freuen sie sich schon jetzt auf die
nächste julia klöckner mit tollen tipps
wie gut lässt sich leichter genießen
wenn man es vorher in scheiben schneiden
der drückt verbraucher zu blöd für die
tonne
[Applaus]